a battleground Republican Congress
person retires Democrats fret over Joe
Biden and President Trump lays out his
pitch again I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show well it's a morning and
that means that President Trump took to
Twitter and stuff happened we'll get to
that in just one second first we need to
talk about the fact that those earbuds
in your ear they're old and they're ugly
and we all know it I mean they've got
the wires coming down from them they
don't sound all that good anymore what
you need is a new pair of earbuds
wireless earbuds but earbuds that are
not gonna cost you a fortune and this is
where rake on earbuds come in ray County
er but start at about half the price of
any other premium wireless earbuds on
the market when they sound just as great
ray konzi 50 wireless earbuds they've
changed the game for me I wear them all
the time they are very comfortable
they're easy to take anywhere unlike
some of your other wireless options ray
con earbuds are both Silas and discreet
they don't have those wires they don't
have the stems and of course they don't
just look right they sound terrific as
well ray con offers their wireless
earbuds for everybody in a range of fun
colors at a terrific price go buy rake
on comm buy rake on.com slash Ben right
now they get fifteen percent off your
order that's bu y ra y co n comm slash
Ben for 15% off rake on wireless earbuds
if denying a pair now would be the time
to get a great deal one more time that's
by raking comm slash Ben bu y ra y Co n
comm slash menus that slash Ben so they
know that we say you also get 15% off
your order today by rake on comm so
that's fine I listen I'm the best ear
buds on the market for not as expensive
as those other ear buds by rake hunt
comm slash Ben okay so there's a piece
of news yesterday that I think is
indicative of where exactly the race
stands going into 2020 and it's not a
good piece of news for Republicans so
today is going to be all about bad news
for both parties it turns out that the
Democrats are less than saying what
about Joe Biden as their possible
nominee because he seems old he seems
slow as I've been saying for a while
slow Joe Biden but meanwhile on the
Republican side the great problem with
President Trump has been that he cannot
contain himself he just does not have
the capacity to contain himself if the
man had one iota of self-control he
would be nearly unstoppable as a
politician but it turns out that with
the good comes the bad and with the good
part of the sandwich comes the
and the fact is the President of the
United States cannot contain himself and
this is going to be a continuing problem
for him and while there are Republicans
around the country who are celebrating
the quote-unquote purifying of the party
they're celebrating the fact that those
those RINO are going away you need
those people to vote for you in 2020 if
you wish the President to retain the
presidency you need some of these
Congress people in swing districts to
remain and in fact some of the best
politicians in the Republican Party are
from some of these swing districts
exactly the sort of districts that
Republicans need so here's the piece of
news representative will heard who's the
lone black Republican in the House and
the rare GOP lawmakers to a times
criticized president Trump will not seek
re-election according to the Washington
Post now the left is taking this as Hurd
is resigning because he can't get along
with Trump that is not the case the
reason that hurt is resigning is because
he is looking at the tea leaves for 2020
and he does not like what he sees he has
already raised it was pretty clear that
he was going to run he raised something
like 700,000 dollars already for the
2020 race and that was going to be used
in a knock-down drag-out battle will
Hurd has been representing the Texas
23rd district since January of 2015
since the 2014 election which was a wave
election for Republicans this has been a
very very back-and-forth district so
from 1992 to 2006 when there was a
democratic wave it was represented by
Henry Bonilla who is a Republican and
then from 2006 to 2010 it was
represented by a Democrat then there was
a Republican wave and for two years who
was represented by a Republican then in
2012 during Obama's re-election campaign
it was represented by a Democrat again
and then will heard came back in and he
won two consecutive terms the last term
that he won he won in an insanely narrow
election he won that election by
something like a thousand votes total it
was extraordinarily close like a hundred
and three thousand votes to a hundred
and two thousand votes and will Hurd was
probably looking at the tea leaves in
his district it was a district that
Hillary Clinton won and he ended up
winning the district that's exactly the
kind of place that Republicans need to
win the places that Hillary Clinton won
but you need a Republican Congress
person those are the districts and will
Hurd is stepping down now what is
fascinating about this district is that
this district is nearly seventy percent
Hispanic so this is also a district
where Republicans are showing their
mettle when it comes to the ability to
get people of racial minority status and
at
minority status to vote Republican one
of the great differences between
California and Texas is the way that
Hispanics vote in Texas versus
California in California Hispanics vote
something like 70/30 Democrat in Texas
Hispanics vote something like 55 45
Democrat
well that gap explains the dominance of
Republicans in Texas for the last 20
years even with the rising tide of
Hispanic immigration into Texas and the
growing Hispanic population in Texas but
what will herds resign resignation shows
what he's not resigning what is
unwillingness to run for reelection
shows is that there is a feeling that
Texas is beginning to turn blue so this
is this is very bad news for Trump come
2020 if it's seen as sort of a
bellwether immediately cook Political
Report stook this district from toss-up
to leans Democrat because Hurd is unique
candidate herds retirement is the third
by a Texas Republican in the past week
alone now the other two Texas
Republicans retiring are retiring in
heavy red districts but the fact is that
a lot of folks don't want to be in
Congress right now a lot of folks see a
bad wave coming in 2020 why not because
of the economy which continues to be
good another economic report today that
puts the US unemployment rate at three
point seven percent a record number of
people in America are now employed some
157 million people in the United States
currently have jobs that is a great
economic record for the President of the
United States all this despite the fact
that there are significant headwinds in
terms of trade barriers and tariffs that
the president is putting in place with
regard to China some justified some
unjustified we'll get to that in just a
little while so why exactly isn't Trump
riding at fifty to fifty three percent
and the answer as always comes back to
the fact that the president cannot
exercise self-control and you can tell
by the way the right is reacting to will
herds retirement so many people on the
right are reacting to will herds
retirement with good riddens that guy
wasn't standing up for crunk when Trump
said stuff he's in a swing district that
is filled with Hispanic people on the
border of course he should be calling
out the print not just not just morally
I listen you know my views on this I
believe that when the president does
something when Trump does something
wrong he ought to be called out the same
as any other human being who does
something wrong even if you like what
he's doing politically and even if you
like the fact that he slaps at the left
on a frequent basis when people do stuff
that is morally bad you should point out
is morally bad this is in fact your job
as a moral human being is to point out
when things that are morally bad are
morally bad doesn't mean you shouldn't
vote for him doesn't mean you shouldn't
support him it does mean that when you
exercise your judgment as to whether
something is morally bad or not it is
your moral judgment that is being called
into question not Trump's moral judgment
that is being called into question
people judge you based on the way that
you deal with things that you see that
are immoral in your life and so I've
always recommended to everybody left
right and center it's my great
irritation with the left is that the
left stands on there they sit on their
high horse and they pretend that they
are the arbiters of morality the police
of morality and then they won't call out
immorality when it's on their own side
and then they look at Republicans doing
the same thing and they say how dare you
I mean the same people who rip on Trump
constantly on the left and rip on
Republicans who won't rip on Trump
constantly those are the same people who
cheer when the New York Times today
reports Chappaquiddick as a Kent as a
Kennedy family tragedy I kid you not
that's in the New York Times today it's
okay guys you can stop defending the
Kennedys Teddy's been dead for ten years
it's okay you can stop it you don't have
to do it that led to the rise of Trump
the the odd graceless nests of the left
the fact that the left constantly
suggested that the right was morally
bereft while touting its own immoral
actors as somehow morally superior that
led the right to embrace a lot of this
stuff but will hurt calling out Trump
when he thought Trump was wrong it
wasn't just I think the right thing to
do in many cases I think that it was the
politically smart thing to do in his
district obviously heard barely held his
seat last year Trump lost the
congressional districts it covers more
than 58,000 square miles between San
Antonio and El Paso along the Mexican
Mexican border by four percentage points
in 2016 in an interview last Thursday
with the post heard had criticized
Trump's and this is just Washington Post
coverage Trump's racist tweets last
month again it is amazing how the
Washington Post will take tweets that I
think were xenophobic but not racist and
then call them racist as though that is
a fact judgment as opposed to an opinion
judgment the Washington Post has heard
criticized Trump's racist tweets last
month in which the president said four
Democratic minority congresswoman should
go back and help fix the totally broken
and crime-infested places from which
they came three of the women are from
the United States etc heard said when
imply that because someone doesn't look
like you and telling them to go back to
Africa or wherever you're implying that
they're not an American and you're
implying they have less worth than you
is what Hurd had to say about this Hurd
also repeated his earlier pledge to vote
for Trump if he's the Republican nominee
in 2020
he said Hispanics African Americans and
other groups would be receptive to
conservative themes if they weren't
drowned in racially charged rhetoric
Hurd said number one you need to show up
to communities that haven't seen
Republicans show up and listen then the
message that you take is how we have
solved problems in our communities when
you look at african-american
unemployment Latino unemployment it's
had an all-time low I heard is the kind
of Republican that you do need he is 41
years old he said he plans to run again
for elected office you would imagine
that he's probably gonna run for Senate
at some point or maybe governor of the
state of Texas he's a former CIA officer
he said I think it can help the country
in a different way I'm interested in
pursuing my lifelong passions at that
intersection of technology and national
security I think I have an opportunity
to help make their make sure the
Republican Party looks like America he
opposed Trump's national emergency
declaration but does favor a border
barrier for example so Hurd has been a
lot more moderate and his approach to
Trump than a lot of the other
Republicans and that has led a lot of
Republicans to distance themselves from
heard in the same way they did from for
example Jeff Flake but heard never
virtue signals in the same way that Jeff
Flake did and more than that Hurd is the
kind of person that you need in that
district that Jeff Flake could lose his
seat it ended up being filled by a
Democrat but Republicans had a shot at
the seat without will heard in that
district it's a problem for Republicans
so why is this so important it's
important because again every swing
district is now a bellwether for Trump
and if he's losing swing districts in
Texas he's gonna be in trouble
come 2020 and again it goes more to
Trump as a character than it does go to
Trump Trump's policy so how is Trump
gonna win over the districts that he
needs to win over now there's this
prevailing theory it's a very sanguine
optimistic theory on the Republican side
that Trump has a mystical connection
with voters and that he will pull a
rabbit out of the Hat a second time that
2016 was not about Hillary Clinton being
unable to pull votes it was about Donald
Trump having a magical ability to bring
out voters who had never voted before
and also to suppress the Democratic vote
in 2018 Trump drove out the Republican
vote and the Democratic vote
and the Republicans got blown out and
here's the thing if Trump stuck to his
actual political pitch he would win and
this is the thing what got you here is
not necessarily what keeps you here what
gets you to the major leagues maybe
you're 98 mile-per-hour fastball but at
some point you have to develop a
secondary pitch 98 miles per hour can
get you through double-a once you get to
triple-a you start to struggle once he
gets to the majors everybody hits 98 and
the President of the United States is
expected to be the presidents of the
United States and that means that he's
expected to provide solutions which he
has done on the economy for example it
means that he's expected to provide
solutions for four groups of Americans
who didn't even vote for him and the
president suggested some of those
solutions last night in his rally and
then he went on Twitter this morning and
he undermined it I'll explain in just
one second first some topics and life
are pretty uncomfortable to talk about
sex is one of those things but sex is
also one of the most important things in
life especially within the context of
marriage studies show that 70 percent of
dudes who experience erectile
dysfunction don't actually get treated
for it for just that reason it can be
awkward to discuss but sometimes things
just don't work the way they're supposed
to that's not something to be ashamed
about health problems or health problems
the important thing is to get them
solved that's what our friends at Roman
come in thankfully Roman has created an
easy way to get checked out by a doctor
and get treated for IDI online with
Roman you can get medical care for a D
if appropriate from the comfort and
privacy of your own home you can handle
everything online in a convenient and
discreet manner getting started is
simple you just go to get Roman comm
/ban and complete an online visit if
your doctor decides the treatment would
be appropriate they can prescribe
genuine medication that can be delivered
in discreet packaging directly to your
door with free two-day shipping dudes go
talk to the doctor
edie can be tough to handle but it is
very important to get it checked out go
to get Roman comm / Ben to get a free
online visit free two-day shipping
that's get Roman comm /ban for that free
visit to get started again get Roman
comm /ban GE t r om am calm and slash
pen go check them out right now ok so
the reason that I point this out is
because Trump does a rally last night
and the rally is fine in fact the rally
is good there's a lot that Trump does in
this rally that is correct
CNN was so disappointed in the
effectiveness of the rally that they
started using a Chiron crowd doesn't
send her back at rally that's not news
you printing a kite
saying something didn't happen is not
news hey aliens didn't land in area 51
is not news aliens did Lin in area 51 is
news
so CNN was desperately hoping that the
crowd was gonna chance send her back
against they could call Trump and his
supporters racist and so they were
desperately desperately wanting but that
didn't happen so instead they just
reverted to a headline and said it
didn't happen in any case president
Trump's rally last night was quite good
in a lot of ways he pointed out the
radicalism of the Democrats he did a
long extended riff on the fact that
Democrats are wrecking major cities
around the country did an extended riff
on Los Angeles that's exactly correct he
talked about the fact that living
conditions in Los Angeles have been
steadily declining that Los Angeles
California has half the nation's
homeless population and they're heavily
located in LA and San Francisco he
talked about ten cities in LA I live in
LA I've experienced the quality of life
here Mayor Eric Garcetti has done a
garbage job and so is the Governor of
California Jerry Brown to the garbage
shop Gavin Newsom is doing a garbage job
when Trump points out that the
livability of America's major cities is
being dramatically undermined by the
ACLU light governance of Democrats in
places like Seattle and LA and New York
and Baltimore and Detroit he is not
wrong at all and that's a strong pitch
it's particularly a strong pitch for
suburban women so back in 2004 George W
Bush won reelection on the basis of the
so-called security mom's this was the
the great meme of 2004 with security
moms Bush was talking to suburban women
who wanted to protect their kids and he
was the man who had stood up to
terrorism and that that's what his pitch
was and it worked
Trump can make the exact same
law-and-order pitch today particularly
about America's major cities he can say
look at the homeless but look the fact
they're open needles on the streets in
LA you can't you know Herbert Hoover
promised a chicken in every pot
Democrats have delivered in major cities
a homeless person on every bench it's
it's it's unbelievable and anybody who
lives in LA can attest to this you
cannot walk down the street without
running into folks who are living on the
streets oftentimes in filth many times
the open needles nearby with open with
open alcohol open feces I mean it really
is egregious this is a good political
point for Trump and it's something that
he hammered last night so that was good
and from bled office rally by by
suggesting that he wants to just do a
normal rally he said we don't want any
controversies which is a somewhat smart
thing to say saying the quiet part out
loud but sure he said we don't want any
controversy for decades these
communities have been run lucidly by
Democrat politicians and it's been total
one party control of the inner cities
for a hundred years has been one-party
control and look at them we can name one
after another but I won't do that
because I don't want to be controversial
we want no controversy okay that is fine
that is fine everybody knows that he's
implying Baltimore there that if you say
that Baltimore is a poorly run city then
you are gonna get into trouble that that
is Trump you know obviously getting
under the skin of Democrats all that is
fine and then President Trump goes on
the warpath against the socialism in the
Democratic Party says listen Americans
are not interested in doing the
socialist he's right about this this was
evident on the debate stage the other
night when the moderates like John
Delaney really took it to Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders this is
evident when Joe Biden was defending
himself from socialists to his left on
that stage people like Bill DeBlasio and
Kirsten Gillibrand here's Trump saying
we don't want to do the socialist thing
no matter what label they use a vote for
any Democrat in 2020 is a vote for the
rise of radical socialism and the
destruction of our great our beautiful
our wonderful American dream we're not
going to let our country ever go down
the route of socialism yeah and then he
went back to the cities issue he said
the Democrats quote deliver poverty for
their constituents and privilege for
themselves great wine true he said for
decades these communities have been run
exclusively by Democratic politicians
it's been total one party control of the
inner cities he said that federal
funding sent to these areas was quote
unquote stolen money and it's wasted
money and it's a shame there's no
question that there is serious
corruption in a lot of these cities and
he avoided mentioning lawmakers my
name's he didn't mention Elijah Cummings
but which is the smart thing to do again
you can make this point without jumping
on to the landmine of blowing it and
then President Trump went on to the rest
of the radical Democratic agenda he
suggested Democrats support late term
abortion which of course they do they're
incredibly radical on this issue every
top Democrat also now supports late term
abortion
and then you'll have like a governor of
Virginia it's not only late term
abortion it's killing the baby after the
baby is born about that
think of that think of that that's why
I've asked Congress to prohibit extreme
late term abortion because Republicans
believe that every child is a sacred
gift from God
and all of this is good stuff and
Democrats are nervous about this
approach by Trump they are nervous that
their own party is running off the rails
to the left so Paul Begala for example
he was talking and Democratic advisor
Clinton advisor he was talking about how
the Democrats are running too far to the
left I mean they're abandoning even the
legacy of Barack Obama who is a very far
left president and they're running even
further to the left here's Begala
talking about how Democrats are setting
themselves up for failure sir Trump's
Trump's picture is correct when Bill
DeBlasio said this about deportations
Josh the vice president should have said
some people need to be deported by the
camel-hair should have said some people
need to be incarcerated you should have
turned Tulsi Gabbard said yes I raised
bail on people who create gun violence
because gun violence is a no but this is
my problem the whole two day debate is I
believe many of these candidates seeking
to win the nomination are setting
themselves up to lose the presidency to
Donald Trump of course he's exactly
right begala is exactly right says Jim
Messina former advisor to Barack Obama
he says why are they attacking Obama are
they nuts what the hell is this approval
rating with Democrats is 96% Donald
Trump's approval rating with Democrats
4% so the fact that we spent more time
talking about a wildly popular president
and not talking about Donald Trump is
just ceases to amaze me
but just politically we are better off
staying on the offense on Perez on
President Trump on health care and on
economic issues that make sense to
voters and I just don't fundamentally
get the strategy of going after the most
popular Democratic president in modern
memory okay and he is not wrong about
this even the editorial board over at
the Washington Post is ripping on
Democrats for doing this and then they
understand what's happening over at the
Washington Post the editorial board
wrote quote this wrote quote I don't
understand why anybody goes to all the
trouble of running for president of the
United States just to talk about what we
really can't do and shouldn't fight for
us said senator Elizabeth Warren on
Tuesday night senator Bernie Sanders the
other major candidate on the
Fields left wing piled on this got us
thinking about some big ideas in US
history like say amending the
Constitution to outlaw liquor or sending
half a million troops into Vietnam or
passing a 1.5 trillion dollar tax cut
for the wealthy at a time of massive
deficits ambition is essential in other
words says the says the Washington Post
but not sufficient the country faces big
challenges such as economic inequality
and climate change the call for creative
solutions they also call for wisdom
honesty and even a bit of modesty about
the government's limitations having
embraced Barack Obama's no-drama
approach to governing often defined by
the philosophy don't do stupid bleep it
would be odd if Democrats suddenly
embraced ideological grandiosity as a
prerequisite for service in the Oval
Office that means first the proposal
should meet a baseline degree of factual
plausibility a bar that for example the
medicare-for-all plan that Mr Sanders
and miss Warren favored does not clear
the senators cannot deliver a system
that provides far more benefits than
other single-payer systems they claim as
their model while preserving the level
of care and access then ensured
Americans currently enjoy they should
make the government case for they should
make the case for government monopoly on
health care if they want but they should
be honest about the trade-offs
candidates who promised big ideas should
be pressed on how they will realize them
the next president should have a vision
of progress for the nation that is
expansive and inspiring it should also
be grounded in mathematical and
political reality that's the Washington
Post editorial board recognizing that
what Trump is saying is true that the
Democrats have skewed way too far left
so Trump has got a pitch Trump has got a
pitch it is obvious that Trump's pitch
is scaring a lot of the Democrats as
well it should mean while the left flank
of the Democratic Party continues to get
more and more radical Bernie Sanders
came out yesterday he said I'm not going
to attack Elizabeth Warren in the future
we're basically a unified front on
behalf of socialism the other night you
appeared to have a kind of a
non-aggression pact with Elizabeth
Warren do you two have a deal to not to
attack each other at least at this stage
Elizabeth and I have been friends for
over 20 years
she's running hard campaign and I'm
running my campaign at different
campaigns what do you think the most I
think the most effective way to campaign
to be honest with you is to talk to the
American people about why the middle
class is disappearing why we have
massive income and wealth inequality
talk about those issues you do well you
try to beat up on somebody else frankly
I don't think that's good politics mmm
so again the left flank of the
Democratic Party is unifying and this
should be scaring a lot of folks who are
in the Democratic Party Nancy Pelosi was
pandering deal hon Omar again yesterday
this is not a smart tactic yellow hen
Omar tweeted out a put out on Instagram
a picture of herself holding hands with
Nancy Pelosi I guess they took a trip to
Africa for some reason and Nancy Pelosi
looking supremely awkward while holding
hands with ohan Omar and then ohan Omar
put out there that they said to send us
back so we all went back together this
is the Democratic strategy it's not
going to work out well for them and
meanwhile the best advocate for the
Democratic moderate campaign is Joe
Biden and he's got a lot of holes in his
record too
more importantly he's looking old he's
looking slow the sleepy Joe Biden think
the Trump was pushing is really true it
really is and here's a montage of Joe
Biden's screwing things up in the debate
royally over and over and over I mean
the man survived but not by much I mean
he's going to be 78 by the time of the
next presidential inauguration go to Joe
303 300 feet in this fight if you notice
there's no talk about the fact that the
plan in ten years will cost three
trillion dollars my plant costs 750
billion dollars that's what it cost not
thirty trillion eight more years of
Donald Trump will change America in a
fundamental way the fact is that the
bills that the president that excuse me
that future president here that that
that the senator is talking about well
first of all I'm grateful that he
endorsed my presidency already we should
put some of these insurance executives
who totally opposed my plan in jail for
those nine billion opioids they sell out
there one of the things that we're
responsible 15 percent of all the
pollution in the country the important
number and Vice President Biden's
remarks just now is that the United
States is only 15 percent of global
emissions would you or would you not
rejoin the TPP yes or no I would not
rejoin the TTP as it was initially put
forward screw-up after screw-up
therefore for Joe Biden people are
getting nervous about Joe Biden's
as the moderate in the field and and
even Biden has to make overtures toward
the left flank
so Biden was asked whether he's matter
he said no no I'm not moderate I'm a
progressive I'm not moderate dude why
are you why are you running against the
one thing that makes you appealing for
my entire career in the Senate I was
listed never below one of one to twenty
five most liberal people in the United
States Senate okay I wish you guys had
called me a moderate when I was running
for reelection back in Delaware you know
it would have been I would have won by
eighty percent but here's the deal
there's nothing moderate about what
Barack did in Obamacare nothing
no president had come closer than they
tried and they tried and they tried
seven presidents this guy did an
incredible thing okay and that is true
Barack Obama was not a moderate he was a
progressive but the people who are in
his party now see him as insufficiently
far to the left it's pretty amazing
Trump of course has the naturally best
bullying take on Biden he's the sleepy
Joe limb through this one he limps
through those debates it is a hole in in
Joe Biden's persona that the guy is just
he looks tired he does I think you did
okay he came through he came limping
through as I say about slippy Joe he
lived right through it but he got
through it he really did I think it was
okay I think Tamala had a bad night last
night I will
but it's really boiling down to four or
five of them mean so again I think that
analysis is correct so what does all of
this stack up to what all this stacks up
to will Hurd retiring Joe Biden having
weaknesses Trump running on the failures
of Democrats that are obvious to anyone
who has eyeballs in a lot of the major
cities in the United States here's what
this boils down to if Trump could simply
run on his policy if he could simply run
on his record he can still be colorful
he can still make jokes Donald Trump at
8:00 turned down that that dial from 11
to 8 he's still gonna be the most
entertaining guy in the field he can
still do the stuff he wants to do he can
still make crowds laughed he could he
did it last night at his rally he didn't
make any real headlines because he
didn't go over the top right he he goes
out of his way to say we're not gonna do
controversy and he rips on democratic
governance of cities without going after
Elijah Cummings by name and suggesting
that Elijah Cummings is is the worst
person ever and all this again that is a
perfectly fair hit and a perfectly valid
hit and a perfectly useful hit and then
President Trump goes on Twitter this
morning and this it Trump at rallies is
a lot better than Trump on Twitter Trump
goes on Twitter this morning as we
talked about yesterday Elijah Cummings
house was robbed over the weekend and
there is great irony to the fact that
the media proclaiming that Baltimore is
indeed a wonderful safe high median
income American city a wonderful a
wonderful place
beautifully governed that the same
weekend when they were talking about all
this Elijah Cummings house was robbed
now his house was robbed before Trump
even talk about Cummings or Baltimore I
was broken into on Friday night early
Saturday morning Trump started tweeting
after that on Saturday morning so the
initial pickup from the media was that
Trump had somehow incited this against
Cummings which is not true it's just
plainly untrue and again there is
something ironic and something bizarre
about the fact that Elijah Cummings is
is jabbering about how Baltimore's
wonderful well his house is being broken
into however is it a good thing that
Elijah Cummings his house was broken
into no it's not a good thing that his
house was broken into crime is bad okay
and just because you don't like you
Elijah Cummings and you're mad at him
because he runs the Oversight Committee
doesn't mean that you should probably be
happy when his house is broken into
that's silly and not more than silly
it's immoral so here's what the
president tweets out this morning again
after spending the entire night last
night saying we don't want controversy
no controversy so Trump just used like
you know what controversy so you treats
out this this morning quote really bad
news
about smart house of logic Cummings was
robbed too bad
exclamation point now here come the
defenders to say well he's really saying
it's too bad he's actually sincere yeah
sure I'm sure
or alternatively he's laughing at the
fact that Elijah how Cummings his house
was robbed
come on dude
like really you're making the case for
safety and security you're making the
case that you need to make suburban
women feel comfortable with your
candidacy you need to throw the focus on
some Democratic radicalism and you do it
rally where you do all these things and
you do them effectively and your next
move is too bad it has guy wrapped lips
they look like the whole point here is
that the defense to the house getting
robbed things that he had nothing to do
with it you don't have to own everything
you have to stamp a giant Trump tee
right on Elijah Cummings his house
getting robbed what what what just what
why why God why it's not just it's not
just a moral it is politically idiotic
obviously and is any of this going to
have any lasting impact untrim the
reason these things blow over is because
everything is baked into the cake for
Trump people know this is who Trump is
they've made their judgments on Trump
why do I lament it because just like you
have that annoying uncle who you don't
really want to invite to family parties
and he's really annoying he may be a
little racist he's really crude he says
nasty things to your wife you don't
really want him coming to the family
party but it'll really hurt your mom's
feeling if you don't invite your uncle
and so you don't think about him all the
time like you don't wake up in the
morning thinking about your drunk uncle
med you know you don't wake up in the
morning thinking about that but then
when he's coming over here like oh god
no I'm thinking about him now I'm
thinking about him and just makes your
day worse the more days where you're
thinking about uncle med the worse it is
for uncle med and the fact is the more
days you're thinking about the economy
being good the more days that you are
thinking about the Democrats being
radical the more days you are thinking
about Joe Biden being too old and too
we b2b presidents of the United States
the better it is for Donald Trump the
more you're thinking about oh god did he
tweet again the worse it is for Donald
Trump as I say I have a very simple 2020
election theory it applied to 2016 too
and it's why everybody got including
make out 2016 wrong whoever is the
subject of the referendum in 2020 will
lose Americans are sick and tired of
their politicians they think all of them
are garbage all of them which is why
Trump is president in 2016 the media me
included everybody who's watching the
data thought that 2016 was gonna be a
referendum on Trump which is why every
time some piece of bad news came out for
Trump anything from the p-word tape to
to Trump saying ridiculous things about
Mexican judges whenever that happened we
all went okay it's gonna be a referendum
on Trump and that's gonna be bad for
Trump and it turned out that 2016 was
not a referendum on Trump it turned out
it was a referendum on Hillary Clinton
turns out that after 20 years people did
not want to show up to vote for Hillary
Clinton
Republicans despised Hillary Clinton
they thought that she was corrupt which
she is they thought that she had engaged
in criminal activity what she did they
thought all of those things and so the
referendum on Hillary went poorly for
Hillary Clinton in 2020 if it's a
referendum on Trump and his personality
he will lose if it is a referendum on
Democrats he will win so how can you get
it to be a referendum on Democrats you
can point it you can do exactly what
Trump did it is rally last night you
want to make it a referendum on Trump
keep tweeting the way the president
Trump tweeted right there it is not
going to work out to his benefit it is
just it is not smart in any way besides
which it is it is immoral and it gives
it again another news cycle that's a
year and a half out okay it's not too
late for President Trump to to stop
doing this but does anyone really have a
lot of faith that the president is gonna
stop being who he is the Trump is gonna
stop being Trumpy I don't think so
which is why the Democrats are basically
looking forward to nominating the block
of wood the the petrified wood that is
Joe Biden because Joe Biden is just
default candidate all right in just a
second we're going to get to the news on
the Senate the Senate passing another
this big awful budget bill we're also
going to get to your mailbag questions
but first it is that glorious time of
the week when I give a shout out to a
daily wire subscriber today it's sherry
Taylor on Instagram who is dealing
with what every person with the world's
greatest beverage vessel deals with the
coveting eyes of others in this
particular picture Sherry's tumbler is
sitting on a kitchen counter brimming
with delicious leftist years as her
bulldog petunia stares with deep
determination Winston Churchill over
there the caption and the dog's face
reads mom give me a sip of that hashtag
left his tears tumblr
good luck petunia thanks for your
support sherry that isn't that is an
awesome dog by the way that is an
awesomely hideous and yet cute dog
pretty fantastic okay so go check out
the leftist ears tumblr and get a
subscription over at daily wired icon
also remember that we do have a big
backstage live event coming up August
21st still a few VIP tickets available
thank you to the Daily Caller for giving
us additional publicity on it we
appreciate it
you can go purchase a ticket right now
at daily wire comm slash backstage the
VIP tickets will set you back a couple
hundred bucks but the normal general
admission tickets only set you back
about thirty-five it should be a blast
to look forward to seeing you there
August 24th Terrace Theatre on in Long
Beach go check it out right now also
make sure you subscribe to the wire comm
you know the pitch just go do it already
come on
yeah I'm just just do it come on okay
we're the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you
all right so I'm big news that nobody
cares about the Senate passed a broad
two-year budget bill on Thursday that
boosts spending and eliminates the
threat of a debt defaults until after
the 2020 election Justin Justin Amash
from Michigan the former republican
congress person points out correctly
today that one of the things people
should note is that when it says that we
are racking up these giant budget bills
these giant 1.3 trillion dollar budget
deficits that those are measured on a
yearly basis when you talk about the 1.5
trillion dollar tax bill that is
measured over the course of a decade in
terms of its economic impact when you
drop a trillion dollars a year above
what you are taking in that is measured
yearly he says spending bills are valued
over a one year period tax bills are
valued over a ten year period in other
words when 1.3 trillion dollar spending
bill is 10 times larger than 1.3
trillion dollar tax bill the spending
bill has 10 times the deficit impact
fact-check true Republicans just signed
off on it because no one is actually
fiscally responsible much easier to pass
spending into law than to curb that
spending which is one of the reasons why
it's just a fact
split government tends to actually
generate in many cases lower budgets
because the fighting leads to lowering
of the budget people don't want to sign
off on as many things together single
party control these two blowout budgets
for Democrats and Republicans split
government sometimes particularly during
the Clinton era actually led to more
budget balance Trump wrote on Twitter
quote budget deal is phenomenal for our
great military our vets and jobs jobs
jobs two-year deal gets us past the
election go for it Republicans there's
always plenty of time to cut again
saying the quiet part out loud right
there which is a bad budget deal but it
does get us past the election there is
the president cheering on a massive
budget deal that betrays fundamental
fiscal principles of conservatism but
honestly that's not from only problem
that is a Republican problem generally
that is bad news for the Republic but
probably good political news for the
president meanwhile as I said earlier
there are record 157 million people
employed in the United States in July
the unemployment rate did hold steady in
July at 3.7 percent according to the
employment report the civilian
non-institutionalized
fifty nine thousand two hundred fifty
nine million of that civilian
non-institutional 163 million were in
the labor force meaning they either had
a job or were actively seeking one
during the last month and of those
people 157 million have jobs those are
some pretty fantastic jobs numbers for
the president there is some worried
about the economy slowing this has been
exacerbated by the president announcing
yesterday that he will impose new
tariffs of 300 billion dollars on
imports from China starting next month
there was sort of a ceasefire in the
trade war and now the ceasefire has gone
the way of the dodo bird this is leading
people to speculate that the Fed is
going to raise some of the rates again
is going to rather lower some of the
rates again try to jog the economy
there's a worry that there will be a
deflationary cycle where people are
buying less and less that consumers are
going to buy less and less and that the
only thing basically holding up the
economy right now is consumption not
investment that is one of the the
concerns anyway Trump said until such
time as there is a deal we will be
taxing them that will raise the prices
on products like cell phones televisions
toilet seats and pillows it could raise
the price as much as 10 to 25 percent so
you would imagine that this the market
has basically suggested they think that
this trade war will come to an end
prior to the election because Trump
doesn't want a trade war going all the
way through the election with that said
is it good for the president that the
economy is gonna take a hit because of
the trade war probably not there's some
good security reasons why tariffs might
be useful the Chinese do cheat on a lot
of these trade deals and they steal
America's intellectual technology case
we made that we should go to the WTO the
World Trade Organization to prosecute
those cases but regardless of what you
think if the president is thinking about
election 2020 so the point that he's
willing to blow out the budget then
raising tariffs on Chinese goods in the
in the lead-up to the election is
probably not a smart strategy the one
thing everybody acknowledges at this
point is that if the upon if the economy
takes a dump at any time in here the
president does not get reelected okay
let's jump into the mailbag Mitchell
says Ben
my first child is ready to be delivered
any day now what is your advice for a
first-time father I'm excited and
terrified all at the same time ready to
meet him but I have to keep him alive in
that scary thanks Mitch
well the good news is people have been
keeping their children alive for
literally hundreds of thousands of years
so I think it'll be fine my advice for
a first-time dad is especially in the
early going understand that kids don't
really get cute until about five months
at the very beginning you may not feel
the sort of connection that you thought
that you would feel everyone always
talked about you pick up the kid and you
feel that immediate connection sometimes
yes sometimes no but it gets better the
kids get so interesting and so much fun
and so fantastic as I always say when it
comes to the the when it comes to sort
of the life cycle of happiness and
sadness when you are single your
happiness range goes up to about a seven
and your sadness range goes down to
about of one and then you get married
and your happiness range goes up to
about a ten and it goes down to about a
negative ten when things are really
really bad it's worse than anything that
happened when you were single and when
it's really really good it's much better
than anything that ever happened when
you were single and then you have kids
and your happiness range goes to
infinity on the positive side and
negative infinity on the negative side
because the worst things that will ever
happen to you have to do with your kids
the best things that ever happened to
you will have to do with your kids it is
spectacular
it's right to be excited and terrified
in fact I think the fact that you're
terrified much is good news because the
things that we are worried about the
things we were terrified about means we
take great care with them I'll tell you
the hardest part of being a parent in in
today's society is saying no the left
says you're never supposed to say no to
children literally you're never supposed
to say no to them but the mark of good
parents is is saying no in appropriate
amounts setting rules and sticking to
them kids like rules kids need
boundaries I know that we live in a
society that says that any boundaries on
children are oppressive that's because
our society is dumb okay boundaries are
necessary for children children seek
them and they thrive when given the
proper boundaries it doesn't mean that
you have to be authoritarian there's a
difference between they call
authoritative parenting and
authoritarian parenting authoritative
parenting is you have rules and you hold
by those rules because those rules are
rationally incorrectly based
authoritarian parenting is because I
said so you should be able to explain
the rules that you use for your kids but
you should have rules and you shouldn't
force those rules Theresa says hi Ben
I'm a cradle Catholic sometimes when I
discuss religion with my peers they
accused me of being brainwashed from
birth to believe what I believe I have a
very difficult time convincing them
otherwise and once they have that idea
in their head they simply refuse to
listen to me I'm wondering if you have
had similar experiences as an Orthodox
Jew and how you overcome this factor
when talking with people yeah of course
I think that everybody who is born into
a religious house
has that experience of oh the only
reason you believe this is because you
were brought up this way and the way to
deal with this argument is to say there
may be truth to this right we are all
subject to the biases of how we were
raised
obviously like for example you secular
humanist you were raised in a society
that values secular humane ideals do you
value those because they're rationally
based or do you value those because you
were brought up in a society that values
those things because rationality can
take you in any direction and if you
think that religious people don't doubt
their beliefs and examine those beliefs
over the course of years over the course
of decades then you've got us all wrong
now I'll grant you the respect of
thinking that you've thought through the
positions that you hold but you need to
grant me the respect of thinking I've
also thought through the positions that
I hold because the problem with that
attack is it's really in essence a
character attack and it's a character
attack that applies to everybody
everybody's belief systems are of course
rooted in the environment in which they
grew up the question is have you thought
through your own beliefs do you have
good answers to the questions that are
being asked of you or do you really just
believe things because people told them
to you when you were 3 and becoming more
sophisticated over time means asking
those questions and answering those
questions and you can reverse the
question and say the same thing to
anybody who is an atheist or a secular
humanist and if they say well I used to
be religious and now I'm an atheist
because I thought things through and say
ok well I'm glad you thought things
through I've also thought things through
and I came to a different conclusion and
it is dismissive into rites of
interrogatory in in a way that is
inappropriate for a normal conversation
to suggest that I've not considered my
ideas while you magical human being have
Sean says greetings mr. Shapiro I want
to say thank you I had a question and if
I should stay at my job and suck it up
you helped me take the plunge into
something new I'm making more money and
more than that it feels so much better
to not be under bad management and
oppressive SJW policies I'm now in my
second annual subscription eager to help
you another's fight back thank you for
your voice well number one you're
welcome you know the the fact that you
move jobs and took a risk
as I've said calculated risk-taking is a
very good thing I've switched jobs many
times in my career I graduated from Law
School in 2007 since 2007 I have held
before I started daily wire I had held
something like seven jobs and that and
I'd quit every one of the jobs for my
own reasons I quit a job at a law firm
because I couldn't stand it I quit a job
working at a radio network because it
was not
moving in the direction that I wanted it
to move I quit a job at Breitbart
because I had significant editorial
disagreements with the leadership over
there I've quit I've quit a bunch of
jobs in order to make more opportunity
for myself or because I had moral
disagreement you have to make calculated
risks and you have to be smart about
those risks do the risks open windows do
they open doors or do they close doors
very often people will quit a job and
unintentionally close the door what you
want to do throughout your life and your
career is to open doors not close them
you and even if you leave you should try
to leave on good terms as much as
possible Angela says haben media like to
show that illegal immigration is a lot
worse under Trump compared to Obama how
is immigration under Bush compared to
Obama thanks well illegal immigration
has been increasing significantly over
the years Barack Obama I don't know
where they're coming up with a metric
that illegal immigration is a lot worse
under Trump compared to Obama that's not
actually true there's been a pretty
tremendous escalation in in family
illegal immigration across the border
and that's why you're getting all these
child separations at the border but
Barack Obama deported something like 3
million people over the course of his
presidency I mean was much higher than
Bush I think Bush was that like 2
million so Obama was dealing with a
border crisis in 2013 2014 so I'm not
sure what statistics are being cited
there Daniel says hi been ever since
Nancy Pelosi has been very publicly
warming up to the members of the squad
there's a visible absence of controversy
stirred up by aoc and her crew what do
you think is at play here my wife and I
both loved the show appreciate the
insights best Ann well I mean I think
that right now everything was put on
backburner to attack Trump it's one of
the reasons why I was pretty upset at
President Trump when when the squad and
Pelosi were going directly at each other
and I thought man this is fantastic this
is great this is WWE fisticuffs between
two characters I do not like let let
them fight I was I was totally into it
and then Trump jumped anything I went to
fight with everyone let's do it man
fight time woo and then they were like
okay let's team up we're gonna have a
team up now and of course that that's
what's papering over all this now well
the breakout into the opening and you
bet it will all Trump has to do is shut
up for five minutes and the Democrats
will break back into what they have been
doing which is tearing each other apart
this is why I keep saying to the
president mr. president it's Shark Week
go watch Shark Week stop it go watch
Shark Week now there's sharks on TV
you like sharks on TV we know go do that
Ashley says been given all we know on
the link between social media and
teenage depression and suicide do you
think the government ought to have
enforceable laws on minimum ages of
social media use thanks I'd love to hear
your thoughts especially given the
weaponization of media by sexual
predators to to ground minors or to
target minors yeah it's an interesting
question I really do think that this is
more of a parental question than it is a
governmental question but there are
addictive aspects to social media and
the notion that a kid who is 12 or 13
should be on social media if the parents
are not doing what they are supposed to
be doing it's it really interesting I
honestly haven't considered enough III
want to consider that more it's
something that I am open to because
again protection of children is one of
the roles of government because kids
can't take care of themselves and if
parents are simply plopping their kids
in front of the TV twelve hours a day
and and not sending them to school we do
have truancy laws and if parents are
allowing kids to take advantage of
social media in such a way that it is
endangering to them then I could see an
argument I could see mmm as you know I'm
loathe to embrace government regulation
in nearly any area of American life but
I could see the argument I could see the
argument here Billy says howdy Ben from
your future home in the great state of
Texas by the way on a personal level
quick note on that one on a personal
level my kids are not gonna be allowed
on social media until they're probably
16 or 17 minimum and even then I would
prefer that if they have a social media
profile they're not actually posting on
I'm not sure they should have social
media until they're 18 like they need to
be old enough to understand that
everything they put on social media is
then permanent Billy says howdy Ben from
your future home in the great state of
Texas yeah I appreciate it two questions
one how would the u.s. get back to the
gold standard how in your opinion would
that affect the economy too as someone
getting married to my fiance next year
could you give me some advice that has
helped you be a good father and husband
I'm a devout Catholic I'm hoping to add
my understanding of what makes a good
husband and father
any and all advice is helpful please do
not hold the fact that Michael moles and
I share the same religion I don't I love
many Catholics Michael moles is not
among them so when it comes to how the
US would get back to the gold standard
it's difficult to reverse the fact that
so many people in the United State
and in the federal government believe
the manipulation of the currency is a
positive good I mean there are even many
folks who are conservative who believe
that the best policy of the Fed would be
to basically set a low interest rate
this sort of Milton Friedman's policy
look at 2% interest rate and then it
would just be that year on year I don't
like the idea of a central government
being able to manipulate currency it's a
way of robbing savings from people it is
a way of the government manipulating
policy in order to cover for its own
shortcomings the way that you would do
this is you would peg the dollar to the
current value of gold whatever is the
current value of gold you would peg the
dollar to a current value of gold ounce
for example and then that would be the
price of the dollar forever it would
never change and that would provide an
insane amount of stability I mean you
want to keep the United States as the
world's global currency this would be
the way to do it because then there
would be inherent value in the currency
in fact you know I used to be more
skeptical of Bitcoin Bitcoin is
basically trying to do this Bitcoin is
setting an actual value to a currency
that is based on scarcity and is not
controllable from above by some sort of
manipulative entity it's all fun and
games for the government to play with
the currency until you create a bubble
and then that bubble ends up bursting
for example as far as the second
question you know how to be a good
father and a good husband I would say as
a father the rule that my dad used and I
think it was a good rule was always take
your kids seriously always take their
concerns seriously treat them as though
there's their concerns are serious don't
talk down to them be authoritative but
not authoritarian set rules understand
your own rules and always treat them as
though they are rational and have good
reasons for what they're doing even if
they don't always and that that is a
good mark of a good parent as far as
being a good husband I would say that
the same thing will holds true try to
put yourself in your spouse's place when
you are thinking about what you're the
killer of marriages is is faulty
expectations the the best marriages are
reliant on two spouses who believe that
it is my job not it's my wife's job and
I'm mad at her for not doing her job
it is my job and I don't have the
expectation that she's gonna do that
it's one of the things that's made my
marriage with my wife so fantastic is
that there are a lot of situations in
which my wife has not been present
because she was doing medical residency
for example my I wasn't angry at her for
that
I wasn't angry saying well you know I
wish that she would do XY and Z it was
no listen this is a marriage this is a
partnership
I'm picking up the slack because that's
my job my job is to do X because she
can't do X today and now that she's
finished with residency she's doing the
reverse I'm very busy
she's not quite as busy that means she's
picking up the slack in an awful lot of
ways if you think first this is my job
not this is my spouse's job you're going
to be better at everything you're gonna
be a better business partner you're
going to be a better a better spouse now
again this arrangement only works with
people you trust this is true for
politics too with people you trust
saying it's my job not your job is the
best politics that only works when
people aren't freeriders and taking
advantage if you married somebody who is
a free rider and it's taking advantage
that's just a bad marital decision but
that doesn't change the underlying fact
that being a good husband is you saying
yes it's on me and not doing it out of a
sense of virtue not doing out of a sense
of virtue signalling words like look at
me the suffering sacrificial man taking
on all these burdens but as a as a part
of making your life better being more
responsible the best people you know are
the people who take on more
responsibility taking on more
responsibility makes you a better human
being I think let's see
Jordan says hey Ben if the Democrats
nominate Joe Biden and they lose what
happens to their party well that'd kill
any hopes of moderation within the party
yeah they'll skew to the left if Joe
Biden is the nominee and they lose they
will skew dramatically to the left they
will suggest that he lost for the same
it'll be basically the reverse of
Republicans 2012 to 2016 now I think it
may have more to do with persona than it
has to do with policy but Democrats
really conflate persona and policy in a
pretty incredible way susana says hey
Ben my wife and I are big fans from
socialist soil and British Columbia
Canada yeah it's good times up there
where everybody's being told to wax each
other's genitals party times I'm
wondering how Elizabeth Warren is being
taken seriously as a candidate despite
being proven to have abused the left's
religion of identity politics for her
personal gain by claiming Native
American ancestry how's that not grounds
for immediate dismissal from the
Democratic Party best Luke well number
one she acknowledged from white
privilege right so this is the this is
the get out of jail free card for
identity politics acknowledge white
privilege acknowledge it you must atone
so she atoned and also she's a socialist
so she can get away with anything the
media love Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth
Moore
is not a great candidate they love her
the two candidates that have gotten
there they're really three candidates
getting this sort of love from the media
right now Elizabeth Warren Kamala Harris
Pete Buddha judge none of them are
particularly appealing but they make the
left feel smart and thus Elizabeth
Warren continues to ride high Jeffrey
says longtime listener and fan after we
were watching the Daniel day-lewis film
Lincoln I thought to ask what is your
favorite historical film also if you had
the opportunity are there any amendments
you would like to put forth for vote so
my favorite historical film is was shall
always remain 1776 I'll uh I'm a
musical-theater fan and 1776 which is a
fantastic take on the origins of the
Declaration of the of Independence is
dramatic it's brilliantly written wildly
underrated because people wildly
override Hamilton and it's terrific it's
it's really great but there are a bunch
of historical films that are really
terrific Patton is a fantastic film that
is also historical obviously with with
George C Scott that is that is a
terrific movie they're really two men
most of my favorite films are probably
historically oriented in some way but
1776 is the one closest to my heart as
far as amendments I'd put forth for a
vote I've always said that I would love
a constitutional amendment that suggests
that every bill has to be no longer than
three pages and on a single topic the
death of democracy is omnibus bills
because all that is is here's a bunch of
crap you can vote for the entire bucket
of crap or you vote for nothing how
about this how about we get everybody on
record how they feel about this specific
proposal and then we can all vote based
on how they feel about this specific
proposal is yeah otherwise you end up
with this idiotic demagoguery where you
have a bill and it's called the say make
America awesome act and you didn't vote
for the make America awesome anger like
right because it blew out this family no
no but it also had funding for First
Responder so you hate the first
responders you know I just don't want to
blow out the spending no but you didn't
vote for it it's stupid how about this
how about we have funding for first
responders and that is a separate bill
and then we have all the other stuff and
those are all separate bills that was
the way that legislation was supposed to
work a final question Michaels has been
I recently read Bill Clinton's
autobiography and was surprised to learn
that he was rather right-leaning
at least compared to today I was
wondering how you would grade his
presidency not counting the scandals
thanks Michael while on foreign power
I would give Bill Clinton a D I think
his foreign policy was quite bad I think
it led to the rise of al Qaeda I think
he was weak on foreign policy he
retreated from the world on domestic
policy I think that his policy was quite
good I mean he in his first term he
started off moving to the radical left
then he got blown out in the 94
elections and being a smart politician
he then moved to the moderate censor and
started cutting deals with Newt Gingrich
to lower the budget deficit to reform
welfare to lower the capital gains tax
so the the fact that that Bill Clinton
governed as a moderate Republican on
economics and on domestic policy and the
1994 crime bill these were all good
pieces of legislation so on domestic
legislation Bill Clinton was like a B
b-plus president he had a lot of good
things on domestic legislation on
foreign policy he sucked and then of
course there was the scandalous nature
of his of his presidency
Bill Clinton could not win a single
primary in the Democratic Party today
not not a single one at least not
running his 1996 Bill Clinton all righty
well we will be back here today with two
more hours of additional economist kept
things I like and things I hate this
would run a bit long but we will see you
here next week if not if we don't see
you here a little bit later today if you
don't subscribe and have yourself a
wonderful weekend and we'll see you here
back here on Monday
same bat-time same bat-channel i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today we're gonna hit on some of the
stories we missed this past week
starting with Mario Lopez he said as you
may have heard that three-year-olds
can't choose their own gender and but he
sense almost immediately cowardly
apologize for that so we'll discuss the
need in our culture for not just sanity
but also courage which is which is so
sorely lacking also is it racist for
robots to be white CNN has posed that
very important question and finally
scientists are trying to create human
monkey hybrids we'll talk about the many
moral problems with something like that
today over on the Matt Walsh show